hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast recent reproducibility of
animal studies and animal welfare
ethical perspective my name is Jim cam
from lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labrys the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars we have a
few important important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the green Q&A button
lower left I would like now to introduce
RJ speakers stay secret and vitola and
magesh Warren J secret is the director
of the ayah took office at the
University of Texas Southwestern Medical
Center in Dallas Texas in this capacity
she oversees regulatory compliance for
one of the largest animal research
programs in the United States dr. Pratt
holds a Bachelor of Science degree in
biology from the California State
Polytechnic University at Pomona and a
Doctor of Veterinary Medicine degree
from washington state university dr
print is a nationally recognized
authority on regulatory compliance
including I occur operations adherence
to federal regulations and policies
maintenance of good laboratory practice
procedures as dictated by the US FDA
that's a line I guess Loren is currently
the director of operations and
absorption systems San Diego and oversee
scientific and business operations for
the company previously after socio
director of scientific operations
Catholic rub collaborated per hour to
latrobe research and expansion of
self-portrait
Russian system exclusive drug
transporter technology she's on the
Scientific Advisory Committee of citing
for pharmaceutical dissolution Sciences
spds in our current role Fatima also
helps support absorption systems
multi-platform testing integrating the
use of in vitro ex vivo and in vivo
model to for testing and tes and devices
melville drug delivery systems
regenerative and gene therapies
formulation performance assessments and
augmenting equivalents of generic
products I will now turn it over to
Stacey for presentation first followed
by Buffalo's presentation later thank
you for that introduction um I'm very
excited today to speak to this audience
about reproducibility of animal model of
animal studies specifically animal
welfare and ethical perspective on this
topic I have about twenty four slides
and I am actually going to use the
polling function as well which I'll talk
about in a few seconds so as far as the
overview of what I'll be covering in my
part of the presentation I've got I've
got a few words to say about the purpose
of why are we here and why are we
talking about reproducibility and with
that I do actually have several graphics
comics in the presentation there's a lot
of stuff out there on the internet about
reproducibility so i thought i would
share some of these sentiments so this
one reads our taxpayers getting their
money's worth with the research and i'll
assume it's a PhD advisor he goes that's
a dangerous question to ask it's called
research for a reason where the cutting
edge we can't guarantee results and then
most likely this PhD student is asking I
don't have to guarantee results and the
advisor says only to me I am going to
talk briefly about ethics and I'm going
to spend a little bit more time on
animal welfare
and I'm going to talk specifically about
i cook responsibilities in this whole
arena of reproducibility with my polling
questions i do want lots of audience
participation and i have a few
conclusions so what's our purpose here
today one of the cornerstones of the
scientific endeavor is actually to be
able to learn from the research of
others that's very important with how
our current scientific infrastructure is
has been built and how it's maintained
and how it will be advanced this relies
on the ability to repeat studies this is
part of what's called validation
validating of animal models we know that
this animal model is a model for this
disease for example and it helps us to
apply new treatments and new therapies
researchers really build upon previous
studies they definitely look to repeat
certain elements or components of
previous studies to make their research
better and the one of the quarters of
animal research is to be able to apply
the information to human research or to
be able to predict few outcomes in human
research and I did want to put a little
bit of a disclaimer on this talk for
purposes of my session I'm actually
going to be us eccentric and I'm going
to be talking about us guidelines
however arm as our state here in a few
slides when you start start talking
about animal welfare and ethics many
times you're talking more about
questions and sometimes questions that
don't have answers and so a lot of the
questions that I pose can be applied
regardless of which guidelines on
applying us or otherwise so
in 2014 I'll are the Institute for
laboratory animal research held a
roundtable talking about reproducibility
some of you who have attended other
webinars and other sessions within this
virtual conference have probably seen
references to this roundtable within the
report from this wrong table is a
statement it talks about recent
publications and statements demonstrate
concern regarding the quote prevalence
in the number of peer-reviewed studies
that cannot be reproduced particularly
those containing data from experiments
using animals and animal models when we
don't have reproducibility when we don't
have the ability to validated animal
model when we don't have the ability to
apply our research to human research or
predict outcomes this in dangers the
entire scientific endeavor it can erode
the integrity of and public trust in
science and repercussions down the road
we can have decreased funding and
support for science for scientific
research and we can have less
translational research so again less
research going into humans a lot of fun
pharmaceutical companies are discussing
their inability to reproduce studies and
a lot of pharmaceutical companies for
many years now have increasingly turned
towards academia for the discovery of
new molecular entities the
pharmaceutical company develops those
new molecular entities and then you get
new drugs and treatments so if they're
not able to reproduce those initial
studies that's a problem for our drug
pipeline so I'm going to do a polling
question
the question is have you heard about
reproducibility issues in animal
research before and I mean before this
virtual conference so so far everybody
has and we've got about a third a fourth
of the attendees responding I'll a
couple people have now said no I'm going
to push these results here in a second
okay let me go ahead and push the
results for 27 people responding so the
vast majority of people have heard about
reproducibility issues before so what
are some of the causes of this lack of
reproducibility the people are talking
about the number one cause of I see
especially within the scientific versus
the lab animal or regulatory literature
is statistical under powering and on
that's simply not having enough animals
to make sure that you're picking up a
statistically significant result I am a
little bit more information about this
in it and it's a later slide there's the
incorrect interpretation of data and a
few authors have attributed some of this
incorrect interpretation to unforeseen
technical issues which have resulted in
a lack of reproducibility there's a
discussion about researchers not
appropriately describing control issues
and/or conduct contradictory or even all
of their data you know how much research
how many other groups how many things
were studied before that particular
scientists published the data data set
that they published then you're kind of
a couple concepts around this self
correction and correcting
the scientific record there is a feeling
that within our current scientific
construct that were not correctly um
we're not going about correcting the
scientific record very well so when
researchers find that there's non
reproducible data or there's incorrect
interpretations that are detected how
the appropriate retractions been done um
and so for many years science has relied
on this self correction within the
scientific record but that seems maybe
to not be working now and the problem
with that is is that papers the
fundamental flaws then live on and I'm
quoting from another source there but
that means papers that can't be
reproduced end up getting cited and that
causes problems these concerns are both
with actually animal and human research
and a little bit more on the under
powering statistical under powering that
actually occurred especially in
neuroscience there's actually been some
publications in that field and as I
mentioned underpowered studies mean that
not enough animals were included such
that true statistical differences can be
detected what happens when you have
underpowered studies is there's an
increase in false positives so the
positives that you see are actually more
likely to be due to chance so it false
positive then be due to anything that's
experimental and with the incorrect
interpretation of data that's where
concern with fraud and data manipulation
can also come into play um there's this
one reproducibility project that i saw
actually a researcher for my institution
is involved with this and this is trying
this particular project that hhmi Howard
Hughes Medical Institute is involved
with it is looking to try to replicate
50 pivotal research projects in cancer
biology it
started in late 2014 they've only worked
themselves through a few projects but
this kind of work is currently ongoing
so my final comments about our purpose
and why are we here I am going to review
the basic concepts of sfx animal welfare
and i took responsibilities as they
relate to reproducibility there's a lot
of questions I'm going to be putting
forth a lot of questions that's inherent
when you start talking about ethics and
animal welfare I've got a few scenarios
that we can discuss and just another
little cartoon one researcher says to
another there's a fundamental flaw in
your experimental design autumn ice or
scorpios and there's a few potential
answers that we're going to examine but
there haven't been that many answers
given in this field so moving on we're
going to start with ethics there are
many ethical theories out there just
just in general the study of ethics I
find to be personally fascinating the
need for our animal research is actually
usually justified from other quote
unquote greater good concept which stems
from an ethical theory called
utilitarianism within that theory that
theory states that the most moral action
is the one with the best outcome so when
you talk about a moral action if your
moral action is to utilize animals and
research for the benefit of human and or
animal health then that's the best
outcome and you should do it and that
greater good is that animal research
benefits both animals and humans I'm not
using the 3 R's as an ethical theory the
3 R's serve as a theory for serve as a
foundation for a more ethical use of
animals but they don't serve as an
ethical basis for the absolute use of
animals and animal research and for
those of you not familiar with in three
hours briefly it's the words themselves
are replace reduce and refine replace
animal models forever
possible reduce the use of animals /
that's not quite the correct
interpretation and then refine the work
of your work with animals it's not my
purpose today to go over them but I
wanted to put them in context with some
of my later comments so again the three
RS provide structure for investigators
using animals that are incorporated into
some regulatory guidelines and I'm going
to scuss a little bit more and when we
talk about animal welfare there's a core
concept when it comes to discussing
ethical issues and reproducibility the
core concept is our studies need to
provide specific or universal
information that can help with other
research in order to conform to that
greater good ethical argument for animal
research studies have to provide that
information as we saw a cornerstone of
science is to build upon the research of
others but if a study is not
reproducible therefore it probably is
not contributing to that cornerstone of
science learning from others is it
therefore ethical so if the study is not
reproducible is it therefore ethical to
perform so again another little cartoon
one researcher is calling another
researcher I settled the methods in your
paper on to the last detail the
experiment doesn't work the other
researcher says well when you did the
experiment when did you do the
experiment on a Friday oh that's why it
never works on Fridays this one in a
very pointed way describes some of the
whimsy that may go into why something
works and it didn't work for somebody
else now that you have when you ask this
ass ethical question if the study is not
reproducible is it is it ethical when
you don't have reproducible animal
studies other than some of the other
things I talked about as far as eroding
trust
science people start saying that animal
eyes are now wasted we have wasted
analyze we have wasted money and time
and we've put now the safety of clinical
trial subjects so that's people enrolled
in human research we have now caused
safety problems for them so there's huge
ethical implications for not having
reproducible animal studies so Paul in
question number two what do you think if
a study is not reproducible is it
ethical there's no right answer to this
there's many nytimes not a right answer
um with ethical questions but it's great
to get the audience involved and I did
give you the option of saying depends if
you don't really want to commit
okay we have about 23 respondents and
eight of you said no and now 17 of you
said it depends so I wanted to point out
three areas of the u.s. regulations for
animal research that could relate to
this area of reproducibility I wanted to
go over the concept though of validity
versus reproducibility validity in the
statistical concept and I say this
without being a statistician the
validity is the conclusion or
measurement that is well-founded and it
corresponds to the real world it's the
degree to which the conclusions about
the data are correct reproducibility
though is really more about the
replication of statistically significant
results in my world you could have a
valid study valid study results those
results are valid for that particular
data setting can't examined but that
doesn't mean that that particular
research can be replicated or reproduced
you would most likely need validity
though in order to have reproducibility
so then we take a look at the u.s.
regulations the USDA states that Isaac
approval requires that the p.i is
provided written assurance that
activities do not necessarily duplicate
previous experiments number three US
government principle for the utilization
of care utilization care vertebrate
animals states that the animal selected
for procedure should be the minimum
number required to obtain valid results
and Ola says that a scientific
justification should be utilized as much
as possible for experimental and control
groups both also in other areas or la
talks about minimizing the number of
animals use so therefore we do run into
some questions when we even look at our
own regulations does performing work for
the sake of reproduced
ability then constitute duplication of
previous experiments who's going to make
that decision is that going to be the
ayah cook is that going to be the USDA
should pee eyes aim for youth
reproducibility when the US government
principles actually desire validity and
those are two different concepts some
very important questions to ask moving
on to animal welfare brief definitions
of animal welfare animal welfare as a
science started in the late 1960s and
early 1970s around in that early mid
1970s the five freedom freedom is for
animals came about that that started in
England and I'm not going to go into it
but at this point in time these five
freedoms are considered kind of a
baseline for animal welfare in the areas
for assessment when you're
professionally assessing animal welfare
in particular farm animal welfare
there's also the thought of coping this
is by broom and Bruin states that the
well thurman individual is its state in
regards to attempting to cope at the
environment and an animal with good
welfare is the one successfully coping
with the demands of its environment the
definition that I lied for animal
welfare is a more current definition
proposed by Frazier and this is where
you look at three different aspects of
the animal its health how its able to
perform normal behaviors and its
emotions that's the affective states as
well as elements of natural living so
the point here that I want to make is
animal welfare is not animal health
animal health is actually in its
broadest con broadest terms a part of
animal welfare but animal welfare
includes more um so without a welfare
and reproducibility that's a little less
defined when people really haven't
spoken about it as much in my opinion
the questions that you have with this
are how is reproducibility insured in
different research environments with
varying levels of animal welfare that
would i've seen alluded to this next
question i have not seen discuss
I could or should compromise is an
animal welfare make the model more or
less reproducible I have some detail on
this so when you start looking at
ensuring reproducibility in different
research environments with varying
levels of animal welfare what are we
talking about we're talking about out of
animal housing animal health the disease
status or genetic manipulations of the
animals animal behavior animal affective
states their emotions some other things
non animal related variables that appear
in the literature people using different
equipment even different reagents can
make a difference on the reproducibility
of the research some of the answers
people have discussed in order to
address this particular topic have been
that we need to publish the details and
indeed some journals are asking for more
information which is probably a good
thing there has been some discussion
about asking for a group whatever that
group may be to establish more detailed
stand detailed standards that thought
though has not gained traction because
there is a concern of increased
regulatory burden with that so it's
talking about compromises in animal
welfare you know should you out a
compromise and animal welfare to make
the model more or less reproducible what
are we talking about so here's a
scenario and this is where a p.i is
proposing to perform a study with a
standard animal model however that
standard model actually calls for
different animal related practices then
what your institution has established
and you feel in your institution that
your standards are giving you a very
high level of animal welfare do you
lower or change your standards for the
sake of animal study reproducibility
again there's no right or wrong answer
here but this is the animal welfare part
of reproducibility
so this really provides a natural segue
into talking about i cook
responsibilities and again that 2014
workshop from Aybar had some very
specific points about what the ayah cook
should be doing in terms of reviewing
protocols and oversight of research to
help try to ensure reproducibility
although that is not really within the
realm of responsibilities for aya cooks
if you look at in the United States at
our regulatory framework so this
workshop talked about how the I cook
certainly has a responsibility to look
at the humane handling care and
treatment of research animals they also
recommended that the I cook do look at
scientific aspects of protocols that
will affect the welfare of laboratory
animals and I went through some of those
animal welfare components earlier and
it's also talked about how hypotheses
are being tested what the sample sizes
are an adequacy of controls so some
questions for aya cooks then with
reproducibility should i cook allow or
approve work that they know may not be
able to be reproduced you're asking well
how could this happen well you could
have a pie wishing to replicate or
slightly modify a study that's published
it was performed in another I
institution but that I cook actually
allowed something that you're I cook
doesn't a wonderful example of this is
tumor policies the two a lot of
institutions have a tumor policy saying
that the tumor can't go above a
particular size that might be two
centimeters it might be one and a half
centimeters there are a few institutions
that I don't even follow sizes anymore
they have other criteria that actually
brings up obvious questions on how those
studies become reproducible but if
you're
I cook says this is our tumor evaluation
method and another PI says well in order
to you know build upon this work I need
to have different criteria that really
puts the ayah cook in a bind and so that
that's certainly something that could
happen I'm actually also seen the second
scenario where results have been
published but then I've either found the
retractions or I've talked to that
institutions aya cook and found out that
there's been compliance issues what do
you do then when your pie wants to
reproduce those studies brings up some
very interesting questions and so this
will be my third polling question um
should I cooks allow or approve work
that they know may not be able to be
reproduced and I think I've pushed a
button too soon okay there we go so
again I have yes no not sure
well great participation here I'm going
to push out the results most 56% said no
twenty-eight percent said yes and
sixteen percent said not sure so moving
on with this now we started getting back
to one of those concepts in the three
hours of reducing the number of animals
used that may not be the correct
interpretation of the 3 R's in that that
seminal paper from 1959 actually
referred more to reducing animals that
are going to experience an alleviation
pain and distress but nonetheless many
people have interpreted that to reduce
the number of animals used so we have a
regulatory framework for that in the
United States and in other countries and
many aya cooks adopt this so therefore
should I cook then ask that animal
numbers actually be increased if I cook
review reveals inadequate animal numbers
for hypothesis testing and sample size
so we have a group saying I Eclipse
really should look at hypothesis size
control group sample size because if you
don't have enough animals of studies not
reproducible but you have the three are
saying maybe we should minimize animal
those things those concepts can be
rather conflicting at times so here's
some of the scenarios I've seen with
this you have a sample size that is too
small to derive statistically relevant
conclusions I am lucky in that I do have
a biostatistician on my I cook and this
is this is very helpful to ascertain you
can see in study design that you might
have inadequate or non-existent positive
and negative control groups unaccounted
for on sex and strain differences as
well as unaccounted attrition you're
going to do a two year you know
carcinogenicity study in rats or mice
you're going to lose some naturally just
due to natural lifespan limitations
how's that even have been accounted for
in your animal numbers and as I
mentioned before under powdered studies
do lead to more false positive results
causing
problems with reproducibility so another
polling question a little bit different
here has your aya cook ever asked to
pi/2 consider increasing animal numbers
either in a total or group in order to
make the study more valid remember I
same valid here not reproducible because
we do have a responsibility to make sure
that the studies are valid and I'll add
my answer to this at my I cook yes we
have asked for more animals on to help
improve validity so great response
forty-six percent said yes twenty
percent said no and thirty-four percent
now thirty-six percent said not sure so
this little cartoon says with this much
grant money on leaks the only experiment
we can do is flip a coin so I have a
quote here it's something on their
website from the american physiological
society's reproducibility journal club
so their question is do Animal Care and
Use committees and ethical principles
such as reduction replacement refinement
the three RS create pressure on
investigators to propose underpowered
studies this could either be within
their grants or within I equip protocols
so another way of thinking about this is
do the three hours and other iacocca
regulatory mandates in addition to cost
and lack a statistical understanding
which are also things discussed quite a
bit in the literature contribute to
those underpowered studies that we
discussed before so last calling
question here I want to know your
opinion on this do Animal Care and Use
committees and ethical principles such
as the 3 R's create pressure on
investigators to propose underpowered
studies
and I have a not sure they're for folks
who don't want to commit ok so I'm going
to go ahead and push the results so we
had about fifty percent saying yes they
agree I thought that that did happen
thirty-seven percent said no and eleven
percent said not sure so with this I'm
going to conclude we're going to go
switch over to Buffalo's presentation
then we'll have Q&A for my conclusions
some kind of take home points here is
that in this area when you start talking
about ethics and animal welfare and how
it relates to reproducibility of animal
studies there's a lot more questions
than there are answers and a lot of this
is subjective and a lot of it takes into
account like a judgment call as well as
institutional culture one thing I wanted
to make sure in people leaving this
webinar is that they have an
understanding I'll be it very
superficially that I include policies
and reviews can actually impact
reproducibility I've certainly seen it
several times since being in a large
academic institution and that the
regulations specify validity not
reproducibility so when we're talking
about reproducibility we're talking
about something outside of our
regulatory framework at least turn the
United States so with that I'm going to
turn it over to Bob sulla thank you
okay hmm we had the space we give a
great overview just now and raised some
really important questions on ethics and
concerns with using animal models that
are not reproducible well my
presentation will focus on case studies
and examples that I hope will highlight
the sensitivity and reproducibility of
using intelligently designed and an
animal models to help predict human
outcomes but I'd like to start by
thanking Stacey and lab roots for
inviting me and giving me this
opportunity to participate in this very
nice seminar this webinar and my name is
Butler Nageshwar and I work for
absorption systems a company that
supports testing for innovator and
generic product development so let's
bring the in cerebro into the in vivo as
a reviewer recently eloquently put it I
mean it all goes down goes to
intelligent design so before too often
we rush into a study I think with a
standard design trying to replicate a
paper without looking at some of those
important factors like statistical power
the choice of animal model the
importance of data interpretation but
undoubtedly there is there's no question
that preclinical models have tremendous
value and play a critical role in
establishing safety and efficacy within
the context of the Living model so as
all of you are aware drug and device
testing begins with extensive lab
research which can involve years of
experiments that use in vitro ex-vivo
and ultimately intact animal models and
if this research is successful you get
to send your data to the FDA for
approval to continue research and
testing and humans so this research that
involves lab animals which we shouldn't
forget leads to many medical
breakthroughs improving lives and
providing additional improvements in
diagnosis treatments and cures so an
important aspect also to establish is
the complexity of these animal models
will be look at it you know we see the
similarities and differences and too
often we focus
on similarities when we think of
predictive or translatable models but
it's important to emphasize that these
robust complex models that there's value
in similarities and differences because
it gives us insight into complex human
biological systems so as a preclinical
CRO I think we have a great advantage
here because we have the ability to work
with drugs that belong to different
structural therapeutic and chemical
classes devices that are being developed
for a variety of disease indications and
therapeutic endpoints so this really
enables us to work with a very broad
spectrum of animal models non and large
within a highly regulated environment
that includes oversights by bodies such
as our own I o'clock of course and then
the USDA and FDA and a lack and what we
have the ability to do is to support
those initial sort of non glp studies to
test efficacy to look at pharmacokinetic
parameters and support that iterative
process of developing a new drug or
device and leading up to ultimately that
the safety studies that are conducted
under glp conditions which provide the
basis for approval for testing in humans
so everything we do really is driven by
these important outcomes which is that
you're trying to enable a successful ind
of NDA submission if you're a drug
company or a PMA if you're a device
company all these models could be
utilized to enhance product value the
so-called 505 B to rout of the pie 10k
where an existing therapy or device is
being modified for a new indication or
dose group and finally the A&D a route
or which is used for the development of
of generics and I'll talk a little bit
more about this last one towards the end
of my slide which is which is a very
important area where the use of animal
bottles to bio characterize a generic
product to demonstrate equivalence is
becoming
particularly important so you know we
have the classic preclinical models here
which are used for efficacy apk and
safety studies these include rodents
rats and mice rabbits canines swine and
ovine model and of course non-human
primate night not going to really have
examples to speak because this is a
model that we have less experience with
but we'll have a lot of other great case
studies and examples highlighting does
the utilization of some of the other
models so in the coming slides what I'm
going to really cover will be the
development of different products based
on those fruit or indication that will
highlight the benefits of utilizing
reproducible and robust and predictive
preclinical models and we'll start with
you know the obvious place which is the
development of oral products which is
you know always a gold standard all
companies want to have an oral product
from a patient perspective no one wants
to get an injection it much rather
swallow a pill so this is a very classic
model very routinely employed whether
it's the rodent or a larger animal like
a dog where you are trying to obtain PK
parameters you know you're looking at
absorption you're looking at
distribution metabolism excretion and of
course it's also the PK PD correlation
which is very critical because you're
looking at the exposure associated with
compound administration and target
engagement so very commonly you know
those routes are evaluated against a
parent or growth like ID to get these
parameters like bioavailability of c-max
d-max your heart life volume of
distribution clearance and so on very
critical to have those supplementary
aspects to this which are briefly touch
on which is the development of
appropriate formulation taking into
account excipient that can be you know
tolerated within this particular animal
model and this really goes to the
experience of the lab that is conducting
the studies there they have observed the
impact of excipient
in a particular animal model if it can
have an adverse effect which which can
confound the results so this is very
important to keep in mind also
bioanalytical considerations or LC ms ms
is of course the very common platform
for small molecules but it's very
important again in the context of animal
models to think about things like matrix
affect your if you're analyzing plasma
samples you perhaps might want to
consider taking the matrix for your
calibration standards from the same
animals and so on all these go to
highlight the point and question that
state we had also raised about the
importance of designing the animal study
taking all these different critical
factors into question so these are sort
of you know routine studies that are
performed where you're using ideally the
same group of animals that are washed
out appropriately and then you know
taking blood samples over a time course
to obtain these different parameters
however more complex models can be
derived using these very same animal
bottles for example you could do
endoscopic dosing in dogs where you can
observe the impact of regional
absorption is there a component of
site-specific absorption is there
gastric instability and and we can
further extend this out to a surgically
modified model where you can put a rat
or a dog's gut with intestinal courts
again giving you the ability to directly
dose to a target site in the gut and
then you know maybe enable development
of a sustained-release combination for
example so going from simple to complex
and the mechanistic aspects of using
some of the animal models here's a great
example because you know food as we all
know can impact pharmacokinetics of a
drug substance through a variety of
mechanisms that can improve drug
solubility you can have increased GI
motility you can have delayed gastric
emptying and so on and so forth and
though there's several in vitro
techniques like dissolution and bio
relevant media that have been
successfully utilized to predict human
plasma profiles after all
administration in the Fed state you need
to have a proper formulation force for
these resolution testing which is
usually not available earlier in
development so we don't have a clinical
formulation at that point so how are you
going to be able to predict if there is
a food effect so the dog is very well
studied for understanding food affects
we've established this model and you can
really explore the mechanism as we have
done in this particular example with an
oncology drug product where we're
comparing a nanoparticle suspension to a
reference product under both the fed and
fasted state and there's a lot of ways
you can manipulate and refine this model
you know you can use Penta gastrin or
samata teen pretreatment to influence
gastric ph there are other treatments to
innovate bile flow and so on so there's
really a tremendous value to this model
to be able to understand or be able to
predict something critical like for
defector for for an oral drug extending
beyond order is the fact that many of
these animal models especially the
canine model is very suitable for
evaluating alternate routes of
administration what I show you here is
an example of intranasal exposure
comparison with oral comparison total
exposure because intranasal is very
important as a route of administration
it has a lot of importance in an ER
setting for example you know the
clinicians have shown that naloxone for
example has a bioavailability of one
hundred percent after intranasal
administration so as as effective as IV
and so there's a lot of development in
this space and the nasal mucosa is
richly supplied with blood vessels it
can you know result in very rapid
absorption and also avoid things like
hepatic first part and so on so we often
see these types of requests to evaluate
formulations by these types of alternate
routes and and compared exposure to see
if there is a benefit in developing this
type of formulation
intra-oral is yet another area which is
becoming you know very very critical in
terms of the the importance of the types
of products that can can be developed
using this particular those root and
when we look at the preclinical models
there's a nice comparison here of the
order de cosas tissue between human pigs
dogs and rabbits and in terms of the
thickness of the epithelial layer it's
very comfortable for human rabbit and
pig but on the other hand dog Pig and
human are very similar because they are
the buccal mucosa doesn't have keratin
the sublingual mikos of rabbit is non
keratinized so there's pros and cons to
each model clearly but if you read the
benefits you know clearly one link
towards rabbit and dog for obvious
reasons in terms of ease of performing
these studies and I'll give you examples
now of how we used both of these models
to develop products that are approved
and on the market so a rabbit model here
the rabbits oral cavity histologically
similar to humans the thickness is about
600 micrometer so there's enough surface
area for us to apply the test article
and so what you see in here is an
example of a drug which is a dopamine
agonist it's used for Parkinson's
disease causes a lot of ms fills
therefore less desirable to use a dog
model and this was successfully
accomplished with an animal model where
you know the injectable version will has
been replaced with a film strips so this
is a very very exciting series of
studies that we were involved in over
the course of a year or longer where we
tested various prototypes film there and
you know again the criticality of
knowing the anesthesia regimen of you
know to ensure that there is proper
administration and X folder of the test
article without compromise
doing the PK becomes you know really
speaks to the experience and expertise
of the in vivo till here so the
application of the strip the procedures
following this and so on all becomes
very very important aspects to ensure
reproducibility of the results and
reliability of the resultant taking this
formulation of products forward so this
really ended up with a PK profile that
compared very favorably to the injected
test article with a very good key max
very rapid t max and tolerability
showing that this is a very much easier
way to treat you know the type of motor
fluctuations are off episodes in
Parkinson's disease so again like I said
this is an approved product now on the
market another very good example this is
now using a dog models a dog in vivo
model where the sponsor was looking to
also the indication of their drug is a
way to extend the patent so this is
something again with animal bottles have
a tremendous provided tremendous value
which is to help to repurpose products
for patent indication so for the new
indication they wanted the drug to be
absorbed more quickly but to be also
cleared more quickly and initial
coursing buckles tissue permeability
studies were performed to determine if
the buckle route could be used as this
alternative route and whether they were
excipient that could help enhance
absorption and upon establishing that
buckle was feasible and their words
there was an excipient menthol in this
case that caused a significant increase
in absorption you know be progressed to
the in vivo PK studies and this was
really quite a tremendous accomplishment
in terms of the number of animals that
were used on a study like this
considering the complexity of the steps
that were involved because a device had
to be used that was placed in the buckle
compartment could localize the
formulation while the dog was
anesthetized and after the recovery you
know the dogs had to be given an oral
gavage
of a huge an acidifying agent because
the compound is excluded through the
urine and ionization would decrease its
chances of being reabsorbed so there
were multiple complex aspects to this in
vivo study which was accomplished
successfully with you know the endpoints
which is a decrease in t max impedance
emacs introduction in the hot lights of
the compound which is what was being
sought to be achieved was was was really
sort of what is achieved here and again
approved product in the market and again
at you know highlights the ability of
the animal bottle to be very
reproducible and predicted so moving on
to another a completely different area
where you know much more complex which
is the eye and ophthalmic studies and
probably an area where animal data
released surpasses human data you know
how much human data is out there because
of the limitations that we can do with
human testing in this realm so really
the regulators responses the patients
everyone is relying on animal data to
demonstrate efficacy to demonstrate
safety and so there's a lot of work that
has been done to show and certainly
inter-species comparison highlights why
rabbit is one of the most well studied
well used models for ophthalmic
evaluations at anterior chamber
parameters are very comparable it has a
you know a large sort of cornea and lens
and therefore an aqueous humor volume
which makes it very amenable for a lot
of ocular testing on the posterior side
the vitreous volume is not as much as
humans but it's still a very cost
effective model compared to non-human
primate in which a very very large body
of ocular data has been generated so i'm
going to show you again some more
reasons factors for why the rabbit
correlates very well with human here's
here's a list of important factors when
we think Kier volume you think
turnover rate the osmolality of the
tears the ph of the lachrymal fluid the
corneal thickness which is very
important we think of penetration for a
topical drop the surface area that is
available the aqueous humor volume and
turnover as I mentioned so a lot of very
good reasons to choose dabit and why
there is such a vast amount of data
using this model for ophthalmic drugs
for a variety of indication so in the
next two slides I will show you some
very interesting data because you know
rabbit as a model has been historically
used in the development of a number of
innovator of brand products of filmic
drugs that are out on the market that
what you're going to see here is an
example of a reference versus a test
comparison for the development of a
complex of tallmadge suspension here
where the human study is is so
prohibitively challenging and what's
more there's a high you know probability
of failure at the end of of an expensive
and large human study so this is
actually prompted by the European
regulatory bodies where they have a more
progressive view in terms of look
accepting animal data for comparisons
poly covalent so the rabbits will use
the eyes are of course similar in size
and shape to humans as I mentioned the
compound in question was an inhibitor of
carbonic anhydrase which is responsible
for production of bicarbonate ions and
is you know class of drugs that is used
for glaucoma so basically what the
outcome here was you know we were not
trying to look at a pdn point like
reduction in intraocular pressure that I
will show you in my next slide in this
particular study we were really looking
only at the distribution of the compound
in the different ocular compartments
when those with the reference versus the
test so basically we measured the test
article following dosing with
each of these products the reference
products as well as the test product and
we measured the active ingredient in
selected ocular tissue and so measuring
the concentration of the compound in
aqueous humor shows us the levels of the
test article that's passed into the
anterior chamber and measuring the
concentration in the idle ciliary body
shows us how much has actually reached
the tissue which is the site of the PD
action so there's a lot of value here
which enabled us to ultimately select a
pivotal formulation that the sponsor
then took into an actual human studies
very successfully the other aspect of
this is utilizing animals now for a pdn
point again in a very interesting
example here we are again trying to
establish equivalence between a
reference article and the test
formulation that is being a generic that
is being developed by looking at the
efficacy and safety of this sponsor
stress formulation in reducing
intraocular pressure after topical
administration in New Zealand White
Rabbit so we actually in this case
induce a hypotensive condition and this
was steroid-induced and then we you know
began to administer both the test and
reference formulation topically three
times a day over a certain time period
of 10 days and then we measured iop and
this is probably a very very good
example to show how critical it is that
you pay attention to all the details
when you come to a sensitive endpoint
like iop measurements because you know
the acclimation of the animals to the
iop measurement taking into account the
cycle the lighten dark cycle taking into
account having a dedicated researcher
who is performing these measurements
these endpoints we've become very
critical in being able to obtain
reproducible data from our study such as
this but what we were able to show is
that there was no significant difference
we had enough animals on the study
the power was sufficient to give us very
strong statistical basis to show that
there was no difference in iop
introduction between the lessons and the
tech so we have actually gathered a very
very large database of data from the
rabbit for all different classes this is
dorzolamide which is a topical carbonic
anhydrase inhibitors we have the data
for every class of glaucoma drug that is
on the market where we have the response
in rabbit and we have the human response
to be able to show the ID ibc here in a
sense between a preclinical model and a
human condition and then really
establish that the animal model can be
very predictive of human outcomes so I'm
almost wrapping up here to show you a
few more highlights or utilization of
preclinical models for areas outside of
some oral and intranasal intra-oral and
ocular here's the utilization of the
force beam model now because of its
similarities with a human in for a very
variety of fields that is itself you
know for cardiovascular applications a
lot in dermatology because the cutaneous
architecture of the fig is so similar to
human and then in reconstructive and
regenerative therapies as well so I'll
show you an example of a dermal models
that we have developed which is a unique
application which is a hypertrophic scar
model where Greg Durak cigs exhibit many
of the features of hypertrophic scarring
that are observed in human so truly
there is no other model where you can
really observe this phenomenon which
mimics the human disease etiology and so
utilization of the thread durak models
in a study that looked at the topical
delivery of stem cells on wounds that
were created has it really enabled the
development of a day
you need therapy which is now you know
again progressing very well so you
create the wound and apply the treatment
and you're looking at plano metric
measurements you're looking at histology
obviously which is the gold standard but
again it is a model that has been
developed and which is now you know
validated to a point where it can
generate reproducible and robust data so
again more examples to show the
application of course of the swine model
of the 14 models in translational
research and surgical models used as an
alternative to the dog and the nonhuman
primate in a preclinical talk setting so
there's a number of different advantages
to the posting model in terms of the
anatomy and physiology involving the you
know cardiovascular unity digestive
systems and so on so again a lot of
clinical implementation of innovative
diagnostic and therapeutic technologies
really depend in our experience working
with many many devices really depends on
the successful development of these
types of large animal models that allow
for the preclinical evaluation of this
technology so in closing you know I want
to highlight an example for those of you
who are not familiar with the world of
biosimilars the FDA published a draft
guidance in 2012 and it's very
interesting because they they emphasized
the importance of analytical studies for
biological products to show similarity
to a reference product but they
emphasized animal studies that include
assessment of toxicity and other
endpoints also to show the safety or
purity of potency of the rest of teeny
tests compared to the reference so this
is a landmark a poster that came out
which showed the efficacy was
demonstrated between a generic and
brand copaxone in an animal model of
multiple sclerosis this genetic is now
approved but it really highlights I
think the value that animal or
preclinical models are going to play
increasingly in the future in an area
very different from what we have seen
before which is the development of high
quality genetics so in conclusion I
would like to leave you with this
thought that it's very important that
you know we utilize these preclinical
models with with a lot of intelligent
design we don't rush into a study
without thinking through about the
choice of the animal bottle about the
power that we want for the study the
type of endpoints that need to be
measured the components of the
formulation that are being used to
deliver the test article the bio
analytical platform that will generate
the data the results and finally the
interpretation of that data of those
results to really utilize what are
probably the most valuable bottles and
research with intact animal models and
being able to take these types of
high-resolution measurements especially
if we're able to induce a disease state
and these animals is really going to
provide a lot of information about the
underlying biology that's going to help
us elucidate for a new drug or compare
for an existing drug efficacy and safety
in a robust and reproducible manner
thank you very much all those for great
presentations and you might see a poll
that pops up right now so please answer
I just like a once again thank you both
Ottawa and Stacey for such terrific
presentation and before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to rely on our audience that
this educational webinar offers free
continuing continuing education credits
there after the webinar is over to get
your CD credits please click on the TV
button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and it's a quick
reminder of how to submit questions we
can see my questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation with
though we're trying to answer as many
questions as we can so the first
question that we have is from millions
and GF could the intellectual property
concerns make the model not reproducible
thank you so this is Stacy and I will go
ahead and answer this one um yes IP
concerns actually can make a model can
decrease the reproducibility of a model
due to IP concerns not all of the
necessary details for reproducibility
may be published and companies may not
be willing to share that information
even outside of publication that has
happened before in the pharmaceutical
industries I personally experienced it
when I used to work at CR ohs that's
something that I've seen a few
initiatives over the years with
pharmaceutical companies in particular
promising to provide more information
about what they're doing to help us that
issue but right now the bigger issues
seem to be with statistical under
powering in academia as well as making
sure animal-related details are
published great thank you thank you for
that we have another question and our
audience member asks how do I choose the
right animal model to test my
therapeutic or device that's what do you
want to answer that question yeah I'm
happy done answer that having you know
showing you some examples now of
different sort of therapeutic areas and
end points where these and you know
utilize different animal bottles and it
really is a good question but a bra
question because I think it starts with
being able to sort of understand what is
the therapeutic invocation and what end
points you're looking for and whether
this is feasible within the scope of the
animal models that is being utilized
then I think the anatomy and the
physiology those aspects those
parameters have to be taken into account
as also other important factors such as
you know the immune response and other
parameters that are related to the
animal you know if you're looking at an
intra-oral product you know rat rodent
model versus a rabbit model the size of
the oral cavity the saliva the pH of the
oral cavity the thickness of the
epithelial layer the presence of keratin
or absence of I mean all these become
very important so it really depends on
whether you're looking at a specific
dosing route or you're looking at a
specific disease indication that whether
that can be induced or those symptoms
can be recapitulated in the animal model
great Thank You Phyllis how many we have
time for one last question and I
remember audience member asks what are
some of the key factors that should be
considered when developing a protocol
for preclinical study you know I think
statistics the sample size this was an
important point that Stacy's brought up
and with reference to an ayah [ __ ] view
on this but really sample size being
able to calculate this making certain
important assumptions which which can be
defended and to to support the sample
size that you're using the study the
statistical methods that you're planning
to to you I think the randomization more
and more I think we're sort of starting
to see the benefit of almost applying
some of the parameters that are used for
clinical studies even in a pre clinical
setting so randomizing the animals too
oops so that you minimize bias making
sure the animals are acclimated perhaps
using any type of blinding methods so
that you're not having any bias again
certainly looking at the PD and the pka
consideration the administration of the
dose of the time points and any adverse
effects that can in fact you know the
animals and thereby the conclusions of
the study I think all this needs to be
taken into account when you are
developing a protocol great points I
would like once again to thank both you
and Stacey for your presentations do you
guys have any final comments I'll start
with Stacey do you have any final
comments um no I think what bus well I
guess yes what possible mentioned is is
true with regards to you know looking at
model selection as well as study design
for preclinical studies there are also
some regulatory guidelines that have to
be met again as that's well mentioned
but the more reproducible that we make
specifically preclinical studies the
kinds that lots who are described the
more translate ability we will get for
Human Research and so in line with the
ethical arguments for reproducibility it
works very well yes I'd like to just say
that you know i hope this these web
presentations has given the audience a
lot of food for thought I certainly you
know it made me it was very thought
provoking the points that Stacey made
and I think we have to keep this very
much in our mind and for consideration
when we are designing these studies
keeping the the use of animals to ensure
that that this is really giving us
valuable data that that you know can
enable development of drugs and devices
so thank you very much for
you're listening to us this moment we're
great today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through august or
2016 as an audience you will receive an
email from lab research learning you
when this webcast will be available for
replay and we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues room and
miss today's lab with it that's all
little things we have for today I would
hope to see you again next time bye bye
bye bye